коли по тобі б'є 150 калібр там або
реактивний артилерія ти відповісти
нічого не зможеш в тебе нема тенісної
ракетки котра це все віб'є відбувся
вибух підрив на танкові міні
травматична ампутація ніг одразу що я
чітко розумів що в мене просто
виливається кров з мене я хочу
нормальної влади Я не хочу щоб моя
дитина була громадським активістом Тому
це моя мотивація навіть поки що на
візочку далі на протезах але боротися за
своє рідне місто
26 років громадський активіст киянин
правозахисник співзасновник партії
нардавладдя Стрілець 131-го батальйону
112 бригада збройні сили України Я до
війни це активна двіжуха
Котра міксується з роботою скінчив юрпак
працював за спеціальністю в сфері
адміністративного трудового права у
вільний час займався громадською
діяльністю
розбудовував з нуля
політичну партію на народовладдя
основною основним Скажімо так базою
базовим вмістом було місто Київ це
протидія незаконним забудовом це захист
життєвого простору соціальні безперечно
питання і так далі я дуже часто так
говорив і на війні і до війни я говорив
що життя одне і хочеться Вже прошити
красиво то мені хочеться емоції мені
хочеться показати що я зміг допомогти
людям
знаєте по всій Україні він має бути
безперечно збережений це ранок вибухи
почув звуки винищувачів ні з чим їх не
сплутає буквально декілька хвилин
зрозумів що буде відбуватися наступний
Київ я поїхав потім в свій військкомат
по своєму району там дізнався про
територіальну оборону де територіальна
оборона проводить набір заїхав додому
зібрав рюкзак
підійшов туди вирішив набрати батька щоб
якось заспокоїти тому що думав що може
не бути зв'язку А виявили що батько так
само стоїть в черзі в територіальну
оборону
щоб нема кінця краю
це про добровольців Київ буде чинить
опір потрапили в 112 бригаду це наша
київська бригада потрапили на Ірпінський
напрямок і воювали на ірпінському
напрямку до ну Власне кажучи до того
моменту як не вибили ворога з Київської
області Ми легка піхота це
заняття оборони Тобто ми сиділи ми
сиділи в обороні
окопалися отримали напрямки можливо
прориву ворога і тримали тримали цей
напрямок
копали так само приймали по собі удари
алтари а артилерії забезпечували роботу
нашої артилерії і в останні дні так само
бригада приймала участь на псів
напрямках конкретно буде окупації
Київської Київської області
в кінці літа зрозуміло що ми будемо
їхати далі тобто всіх було Це бажання
тому що там йшли захищати першу чергу
наше рідне місто але і ключова історія
це рідна рідна країна поки ворог на
території нашої держави ми були готові
воювати і розуміли що буде ми їхати далі
на схід на початку осені Ми вирішили на
Схід це
Північний схід це кордон Донецької
Луганської областей це ліс під криміною
це де на той момент Це була свіжа де
окупована територія в результаті
Харківського наступу і там тримали і
оборону і в деяких моментах приймали
участь в наступальних операцій і
відвойовували е-е нашу українську
територію що по суті декілька місяців
оборону проти регулярних російських
військ проти дуже добре укомплектованих
сил
приватної військової кампанії
тримали оборону саме бійці 112 бригади
тобто звичайно три це було досить важко
буду відвертим засобів було не так
багато і
були такі випадки що по суті Стрілецький
підрозділ легкої піхоти стримував
наступальні наступальні операції дуже
значно переважаючих сил ворога і коли по
тобі б'є 150 калібр там або реактивний
артилерія
Ну ти відповісти нічим не зможеш в тебе
нема тенісної ракетки котрі це все
відіб'є тобто Ти лише шість ну згадуєш
Наскільки ти добре окопався згадуєш
якісь молитви І сподіваєшся що тебе
принесе
це сталося 20 жовтня 22-го року
зранку отримали нову задачу за день до
цього я вже виходив на нуль приїхав
поспав Там буквально пару годин і
самого-самого ранку отримали наказ
висуватися під криміну нова бойова
задача вихід на нові позиції на нуль це
територія котрий не читав набула де
окупована тобто і територія
безпосередньо де
уже є контакти з ворогом це сіра зона
Тобто там де себе взагалі спокійно
почувають що стосуються ворога та там
постійно змінюється
змінюється оперативна обстановка ми
висунули туди і коли я вже фактично був
е-е
під'їхав під'їжджав до нуля ми наїхали
на британку міну це британкова Міна типу
тем Це там під 8 кг тротилу
я найшов своїм колесом відбувся вибух
підрив на британкові міні
травматична ампутація ніг одразу
важкі переломи рук від вибухової хвилі і
ще була хвиля
вогняна хвиля це опіки дуже серйозні
опіки трьох пальців на правій руці тобто
в
реанімації їх уже сказали про те що їх
будуть планують ампутовувати ну пальці
вдалося вберегти Слава Богу завдяки
робочі лікарів
так само полетів після вибухової хвилі
полетів мотор в обличчя добре що був в
шоломі вибив зуби зламав ніс зламав
щелепу але
найцінніше що є у людини мозок він
залишився Не ушкоджений ну за
виключенням друзі і струшу головного
мозку Я через декілька хвилин прийшов до
тями почав кричати тобто з пам'яті ще
пам'ятаю
кричав я тому що я чітко розумів що в
мене просто виливається кров з мене
все обличчя було в крові Я нічого не
бачу Тобто я не знав дехто Я не чув
нічого тому що була контузія і тобто був
страх що ти один але ти чітко розумієш
ти помираєш відповідно я подумав що ну
ніхто мене не осудить якщо я перед
смертю покричу я почав кричати і за
декілька хвилин Все ж таки хлопці почули
прокидатися від контузії і почали
розуміти що хтось все-таки кричить і
підійшли до нас почали надавати допомогу
що мене врятувало це те щоб менше ніж за
годину десь хвилин за 30 не більше з
моменту вибуху Я був на стабілізаційному
пункті два тижні реанімації в Дніпрі
боротьба за життя критичний стан
температура 40,6
дуже високий дуже високий спочатку
високий тиск потім понижений тиск потім
вже коли привезли в Дніпро перестав
взагалі триматись тобто перестав тримати
тиск це досить досить було критично той
момент тому що мене привезли в тому
стані що мене треба було оперативно
негайно оперувати явне кажучи був в тому
стані коли за всіма
протоколами підручниками в такому стані
людина не оперується в мене наступний
день поруч була кохана батько мама
кращий друг Тобто всі по суті близькі
люди були поруч зі мною і їм було дуже
важко тому що їм не давали прогнозів
Тобто їм не відповідали на питання чи
буде він жити не повернеться до
активного життя як зараз стоїть питання
чи буде він жити
Вони потім зізналися коли я через два
тижні переводився в Київ вони зізналися
що Власне кажучи вони не вірили що я
переживу хоча б день що я дуже буду
ранку
Це було дуже важко Ну я скажу Так це
було
супер-супер-супер важко тому що це була
справжня боротьба за життя Ти
несправного тижня просто не міг не міг
спати ці два тижні мені плюс-мінус
вартувало десь як два роки по відчуттю я
Це досі відчуваю як два роки і я
повернувся до свого рідного міста я там
уже починав відчувати що ми далі
розпочинаємо боротьбу за повернення до
життя а не просто за життя все було
набагато приємніше ніж боротьба за життя
в реанімації
як янунь я народився в Києві в мене
батьки з Києва для мене Київ - це місто
Зелене місто з парками Тому це спонукало
мене боротися з незаконним будівництвом
це пам'ятка садиба барабана це е-е та
пам'ятка котра мабуть найближчим
найближче Найбільше мені запам'яталося
тому що це було останні мирно літо в
Києві перед повномасштабною війною перед
тим як я пішов на фронт це літо 21-го
року
ми зібралися підтримали
активних людей активну місцеву громаду
котра вийшла боротися за свій життєвий
простір проти тітушок проти
місцевої влади котра підтримувала тут
забудовника як би мали побудувати
багатоповерхівку і знести будинок однак
це центральний історичний Реал закон
України про охорону культурну спадщини
Власне кажучи забороняє тут таке
будівництво ми перший ініціатива в
Україні по незаконним по зупиненню
незаконного будівництва по якій я
рішення Ради
Безпеки національної оборони рішення
РНБО є по цій будівлі щоб її відновити
на наступний день
26 років Я хочу писати щось серйозніше Я
хочу наприклад розповідати про війну Я
хочу займатися реабілітацією військових
Я хочу зайнятися своєю реабілітацією а
не писати про корупцію в органах
місцевої влади під час Великої
повномасштабної війни але я змушений цим
займатися тому що нічого не змінилося
тому що як і два роки тому як і зараз у
нас є факти незаконних будівництв в
місті Києві я втомився точкову
перемагати я втомився валяти паркани я
втомився цим цим займатися Я хочу
більшого Я хочу нормальної влади Я не
хочу щоб моя дитина була громадським
активістом Тому це моя мотивація навіть
поки що на візочку далі на протезах але
боротися за своє рідне місто
Я пам'ятаю грудень місяць 22-го року я
військовому госпіталі Ну я ще слабкий
був в мене була температура Я тільки
відходив від праці я почав двома руками
тому що два пальцями тому що три пальці
ще були обгорілі я почав нарешті
повертатися до соціальних мереж чимось
цікавитись я думав про те як же мені
написати перший допис тому що ну шалена
підтримка була в соціальних мережах
однак слуги народу з разом з ПСЖ з
проросійською п'ятою колоною вони разом
абсолютно
незаконно притягнули антинародної
законопроект 56-55 в комітеті попри
зауваження назк докотих долучилися Наша
команда щоб були зауваження
національного агентства з питань
запобігання корупції вони притягнули в
комітеті Де цей законопроект за рахунок
голосу народного депутата від опзж котра
не було в парламенті мене це дуже сильно
вкурвило Я дуже сильно розізлився тоді
так сталося щоби і перший допис На жаль
для мене стосувався не моєї родини котра
була зі мною поруч не мого поранення не
другого життя не Перемоги смерті а
стосувався цього от ці от ганьби оці от
протягування 56-55 Що мені говорить по
цій наприклад будівлі законопроект 56-55
Шуляк а він мені говорить про те що якщо
видані дозвільні будівельні документи
то значить це в порядку то значить у
мене тепер нема важеля яку активіста
щось я протестувати документи ж видані
тобто раніше був механізм оскарження
вказати на те що порушена генплан
порушено процедуру порушено
функціональне призначення зараз дозвіл а
дозвіл дається на підставі містабудів
первинної дозвільної документації він
грає він грає ключову роль для
забудовника нам по суті просто зав'язали
руки тому що не сподобалось що в деяких
моментах От наприклад тут на Подолі
парках нам вдається в судах перемагати
їм це не сподобалось вони вирішили
написати цей антинародний законопроект
Олена Шуляк голова голова правлячої
партії слуг народу автор цього
законопроекту вона прийшла до мене в
палату через мій рідкий допис про неї
Про цей законопроект і вона прийшла на
розборку Це було дуже дико що мені
максимально було неприємно що вона
прийшла поговорити зі мною як з таким
хворим на голову військовим птсником Я
таким
не являюсь я
усвідомлюю про що я пишу завжди я
усвідомлюю коли я виходжу на вулицю
протестувати я виходжу за що я
усвідомлюю постійно за що я протестую я
усвідомлюю чому я тут я усвідомлюю тому
що я за історичний Київ а не за бетонний
Київ Олени Шуляк про інше
Я розумію що саме через цей резонанс не
підписаний законопроект Я розумію що
саме через цей резонанс в тому числі
нещодавно європарламент в резолюції
своїй в одному з пунктів е-е згадав цей
законопроект він звернувся до президента
України Зеленського не підписувати його
закликав не підписуватися законопроект
тому що вони чітко усвідомлюють що він
має негативний наслідки для суспільства
для країни для держави для нашого народу
в нас насправді два ворога на зовнішні
вороги внутрішній ворог
зовнішню борг зрозуміло Хто це Російська
Федерація а внутрішній ворог - це
корупція і ті ділки котрих і захищають
працюють тих карман на їх збагачення
зокрема моя бригада мій батальйон він
складається на 100% з добровольців з
киян з активних людей це ті люди котрі
хочуть змін в країні тобто вони хочуть
незалежну країну суверенну країну Вони
взяли заради цього зброю в руки але вони
хочуть змін вони хочуть Жити щоб ця
країна процвітала я активна людина Я за
цим слідкую тому що я чітко для себе
усвідомлюю що це моє майбутнє це моя
країна Я з нею нікуди не збираюся
виїжджати відповідно Блін мені цікаво
мені цікаво Куди йдуть кошти Мені цікаво
які закони приймаються
Я відчуваю себе дуже погано Дуже погано
тому що я живу в столиці Я народився Я
живу в столиці тобто тут найбільше
бюджет в країні 65 млрд грн це більше за
будь-який обласний бюджет
і Мені прикро тому що Київ не інклюзивне
місце віддавав взагалі тобто
інклюзивність і Київ не можна писати
разом ці слова це різні планети Я зараз
військовий Ветеран я маю право на
нормальне життя я маю право на нормальне
пересування це містом і має право
поїхати до своїх батьків Я маю право з
друзями відвідати ресторан я маю право
поїхати в лікарню в торгівельний центр і
купити не гірший одяг ніж у наших
чиновників і мене в цьому обмежують
На жаль по правій нозі пішло від
вмирання і на правій ножів перші дні
були коліна це дуже було можливо для
протезування але там на шальках терезів
уже стояло не протезування стояла або Я
втрачу нирки і якщо я втрачаю нирки Я
втрачу скоріш за все життя або Ми
піднімаємо рівень ампутації то
відповідно лікарі підняли рівень
ампутації я зараз уже на фінальному
етапі протезування протезування нижніх
кінцівок це гідравлічні колінні модулі
четверта група мобільності але в мене
найважча ампутація буде тільки може бути
це обидві кінцівки парна ампутація
висока у мене на ногах немає зараз колін
тобто мені потрібні колінні модулі це
досить важке протезування особливо коли
це стосується парної ампутації і в моєму
випадку
гідравлічні ці протези вони дадуть в
принципі непогану групу мобільності
четверту але ну мені цього буде трошки
замало тому що я хочу повернутися до
акти громадського життя до того чим я
жив до поранення мої друзі вже чітко
розуміли що їх буду повертатися до
активного життя і ще в реанімації
відкрили збір на електронні електронний
протез найсучасніший протест котрий
тільки може бути на такі ампутації це
німецький отак дженіум х3-й - це
електронний протез але він і
найкоштовніший серед претензів на ноги
тобто отой вот гідравлічний протест
покриває держава
мені як військовослужбовцю але на жаль
електронний протез держава не покриває і
вартість електронного протезу 2,5 млн за
один колінний модуль електронний А мені
потрібно два Я мабуть назву це народні
ноги тому що
якщо там перевести в кількість людей
котра задонатива на це кількість
перевалить там за тисячі за тисячі людей
я ще більше захопився українцями
наскільки це було Можливо я завжди був
захоплений ми Нескорена нація минація
котра постійно відповідала коли нас
намагалися пригніти колись намагалися
знищити коли в нас намагалися завоювати
ми гордий Народ я завжди це знав і
вкотре переконався коли стояв в черзі до
військкомату зараз котра переконався
коли отримав важке поранення тобто
повчинкам людей я хочу сказати що я
пишаюся те що я українець Я пишаюся
власним народом мені росіяни люблять
писати повідомлення Чи вартувало воно
того чи пішов би ти
однозначно так